a raíz del aumento de contagios por
viruela del mono las autoridades
mundiales se han puesto en alerta según
el último censo se han registrado más de
1000 casos en brasil en esa nación ya se
ha informado de la primera muerte
relacionada con el virus fue noche el
ministerio de salud ha sido notificado
sobre una muerte relacionada con la
viruela del mono se trata de un paciente
con otras comorbilidades relevantes y
con antecedentes de tratamiento de
quimioterapia si había indicios de que
el motivo de la muerte estaba
relacionado con el virus también se han
registrado dos muertes en el continente
europeo en españa esto le lleva el
número total de muertes relacionadas con
la viruela del mono a tres fuera de
áfrica donde la enfermedad endémica se
detectó por primera vez en humanos hace
más de 50 años la enfermedad que provoca
fiebre alta inflamación de los ganglios
linfáticos y una erupción parecida a la
varicela afecta principalmente a los
hombres que tienen relaciones sexuales
con otros hombres pero las autoridades
han advertido de los riesgos de
estigmatizar a una comunidad concreta e
íntima nahla ese tipo
esto sí se demoniza a la gente deja
hablar de ello o no busca ayuda médica o
no informan de los casos y una vez que
cualquier virus o cualquier infección
pasa a la clandestinidad es imposible de
rastrear y de repente vemos una
explosión de muchísimos casos de
explosión y menny mexiquense que desde
mayo se han detectado unos 18.000 casos
de viruela del mono en todo el mundo lo
que ha llevado a la organización mundial
de la salud a declarar la emergencia
sanitaria mundial el organismo rector
también está animando a la vacunación de
las poblaciones de riesgo pero afirma
que el número de vacunas disponibles en
todo el mundo sigue siendo insuficiente
mientras tanto las autoridades
sanitarias recomiendan a las personas
expuestas a la enfermedad vírica que
tomen más precauciones de seguridad y
limiten su número de parejas sexuales